welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss this is fully
wow filet mignon welcome back to new
rockstars i'm eric voss this is philip
molina
guys there are some major bite-sized
questions that i'm really excited
uh about getting the answer that eric is
gonna tackle this week this one's from
yana llama yana llama yana llama
what was thanos cooking on the farm
planet and
end game yeah yeah yeah an end game he's
like he's got
he's got a full sequence where it's just
like a cooking show
[Music]
well we don't have an answer for this
but we can kind of look at some clues
it looks like some kind of stew it's in
a kettle over a fire he picks these
plants from his farm
they look like some kind of either a
fruit or vegetable similar to
a tomato or an ear of corn or a squash
that you can just kind of like
pick off it's not a root vegetable like
a potato it probably wouldn't be a fruit
unless it's like a tomato because fruits
are usually sweet you want something
more savory
if you're gonna make a stew squash
sounds like a good option my guess is
he's making like a butternut squash
style
stew or a bisque he does season it which
implies that he has taste buds
what's interesting is if you look at the
comics thanos does not require
food that's comics thanos he uses the
energy of like infinity stones to
sustain himself
so but also remember the condition that
he's in he's basically got like the flu
yeah he's there and so he's like i'm
gonna make my you know old chicken
noodle he's limping and he doesn't have
the stones anymore he reduced them to
atoms
also like anybody who does fitness knows
you can't get that jacked without having
like a heavy calorie intake every day
give me all the bacon and eggs you have
every villain has just got a huge
physique but like
he needs some kind of gravity to work
against his muscles for them to grow
that large
but he doesn't have taste buds if he
seasons it like he wouldn't season food
unless he cared about how it tasted
that's the question we care about does
thanos have taste buds yeah i think it
is something interesting that like
he seasons it and it reminds us it
evokes when vision spices the pepper
cache
like is he trying to evoke what vision
did because vision can't taste either he
doesn't understand the concept of taste
so maybe there's like a bit of a vision
soul that's speaking through vision in
that moment
do you guys want a breakdown of all the
superhero tongues in the mcu
congratulations uh in the meantime at
julia wow
shower how common is arthur flex
pathological laughter disorder if it's
real
it is real it's based on a real
condition it's not named in the movie
but the closest analog we have in in our
medical
science it's called pseudobulbar affect
or pda
and it's actually it's something that's
common among uh stroke victims so it's
characterized by frequent involuntary
bouts of crying laughter or other
emotional displays
exaggerated or disconnected from the
individual's actual emotional state
so this is something that is actually
fairly common it's caused by brain
injuries neurological disorders
uh that impact the part of the brain
that uh controls how we process emotion
and according to the mayo clinic it
affects one million people in the united
states a million
a million living right now up to a
million because a lot of people suffer
from brain injuries
a lot of people get in car accidents or
they're older and they have strokes they
don't process emotion the same way
it's not like arthur fleck walking
around in some cases it is but most of
the time it's people who are suffering
from a lot of other
conditions as well and that's kind of
like the least of your worries the fact
that they're laughing when they
shouldn't be laughing or crying when
they should be crying just to give you a
sense of the scale one million people is
roughly the size of the population of a
lot of cities like san jose california
has a million people it's half of miami
yeah uh half of our subscribers
have uh inappropriate emotional
responses to things i mean that's
all of them yeah yeah uh as do we uh
that's super
interesting that it's that high in
number here's the real question then
what happened to the joker's brain he
was tortured as a kid right he was
abused by
penny flex's ex-boyfriend who tied him
to a radiator
and his brain was pressed against the
heat
of a radiator uh i don't know if that
would be enough to damage it you think
that would be like a flesh wound as
opposed to like brain
damage but like if he's doing that to
him he might also be like
beating that crap out of him also
radiator's radioactive probably right
that's how they work right that's where
you get the heat from if you live in
canada you might need a radioactive
radiator what's this character because
it's so cold up there
this is uh i'm a snowman a canadian one
right
not a canadian oh it's kind of southern
hello present day eric here i
just wanted to thank you guys for
supporting us and we hope you are
enjoying these classic bite size
segments
they are classic they're segments that
we realize not all of you guys have had
the time to watch because we know
they're buried in other videos kind of
hard to find and uh we know
most of you have not seen them because
we keep getting asked these questions
from you over and over again which is
totally fine they are
very good questions and we have made
great answers that we are so happy to
help get more eyeballs on
pre quarantine eric is coming back to
answer the next question for you but
real quick before we move on i want to
thank the ridge for sponsoring this
video
they are the makers of these sleek front
pocket wallets the ridge wallet is light
and sleek and
industrial it is designed to fit in your
front pocket unlike those bulky 90s
style back pocket wallets
that give you an america's ass no one
would want a salute this one
is their black titanium model it's so
slick you can do some sleight of hands
with it i don't know how to do magic i
just feel cool holding it when you head
out the door for like a quick errand
to get whatever essential stuff that you
need you just take the minimal
essentials with you to make for a quick
hassle-free transaction that's what
these ridge wallets are perfect for the
ridge wallet comes in over 30 styles and
colors including carbon fiber burnt
titanium it holds up to 12 cards
and still has room for cash every ridge
wallet comes with a lifetime guarantee
and they will let you test drive it for
45 days
and then send it back for a full refund
if you don't love it but it's got thirty
thousand five star reviews so you know
they're doing something right they also
have great backpacks and travel bags
with rfid blocking pockets optional
device charging batteries
and ridge wallets are apparently
chainsaw proof so you know when jason
voorhees kicks down your door at least
your credit cards will be okay
get 10 off today with free worldwide
shipping and returns by going to
ridge.com new rockstars that is rich dot
com slash new rockstars user code new
rockstars find the link in the video's
description
this one's from at spillyspitz
great name in the walking dead jerry's
axe
cuts a dude in half but then is also
unable to
just cut a lock on a chain so the
question
is is this a mistake should an accident
cut a person clean in half
be able to just cut through a lock great
question we're constantly wondering this
when we're watching the walking dead
it's a i tried it yeah we did we
demonstrated
r.i.p the thing with the walking dead is
it's all about like
the whatever delivers the most gross out
gore because that's why we're watching
the show at this point now the question
is referring to in season eight episode
four
uh the savior gunther has kidnapped
ezekiel
and jerry his henchman who has his big
battle axe saves ezekiel right when he's
about to die
by cutting the dude in half vertically
through like his collarbone through his
chest
basically we see a shot of his back and
like flesh
splits open and we just see zeke will be
like we don't know how clean
like jerry takes another whack at it we
don't really hear a clear sound and
to tell us oh what body part was slashed
open there
but it's implied that in one clean
swipe he's able to split the sky in half
like a pumpkin you're able to tell based
on the sound what body part has been
played well you can't
not anymore i bet like foley artists if
you were to play like a specific sound
effect be like
that's the next snap please broke his
foot but
what's crazy about is this same ax
they're trying to get away from some
walkers
and he can't hack open a chain that's
keeping the gate closed
now the thing about this is is uh
researching this a metal steel chain is
actually
very very hard to cut with an axe uh
there is a youtuber
his name is wrangler star and does this
kind of stuff like in
a metal shop all the time to see like
it's kind of like a will it blend type
thing
uh will it axe let's talk about that he
was trying to
test to see if the scene in cool hand
luke where a chain is cut
he tried to do it and was not able to do
it because every time he tried to chop
it it was just the blunt force
blow of the axe swing would just push
that metal link
into the wood of the surface that it was
resting on so it wouldn't cut it
it requires a tremendous amount of
strength on both sides newtonian third
law there
so what he was able to do is to get a
steel surface so he needed a strong
steel surface pushing back against the
axe blow
to wedge all that force on the link
itself and only then he was able to cut
it
almost all the way through but it was
very hard and he had to get a full swing
so jerry doesn't have any such force
pushing back against that
chain so yeah it would be really hard
for him to split a
steel-linked chain open which has a much
much higher tensile strength
than human flesh and bone what is kind
of crazy
about this moment is the fact that jerry
could cut open a human
with one blow of an axe yeah it would it
would wedge probably in gunther's chest
and then it would take him down but
wouldn't split him open like where's the
entry point uh the entry point
it's they don't show the entry point but
yeah it's not like completely straight
down the head
because the skull is actually very hard
i think i saw a mythbusters episode on
that the skull is not easy
to break or just split open like that
you can fracture it for sure
and the femur are the are two of the
strongest bones in the body but going
through the collarbone the collarbone is
very easy to break
i believe so it's a diagonal yeah it's
kind of like a
seat belt cut an 80 degree angle i would
say yeah seat belt cut is safe
and it kind of goes through we don't
know if it goes through like his crotch
or his legs but it's implied that it
at least goes through his chest and then
it splits open like a pinata now we
don't know how much calcium gunther's
getting
but it's safe to assume that that part
was ridiculous it's just done for shock
value
but it is plausible that jerry should
not have been able to open that link so
that part of it is safe
to say great all right bite size
question answered uh bite size is gross
when we're talking about this
that's been this week's episode a big
question a reminder to hit us up with
the questions for next week using the
hashtag bigquestion
you can get featured on the show one of
these silly uh
twitter handles will be yours next week
and uh and let us know what you like
about this show if you want to see
different kinds of questions answered
where we just love making this an
interactive q a thing where we can
finally
uh have an opportunity to answer the
things you guys have always been asking
us so we can't be in the other videos
i've been eric voss i'm slightly drunk
make sure to follow us at eavos at
philip molina
on on everything and see you next week
[Music]
you